hi guys we're the cast of Riverdale and
we are going to be reading your thirst
tweets on BuzzFeed here we go
[Music]
every single dad on is adults every
single one I agree yeah yeah I agree
holy mama you are more than hot help
I'm literally can't think straight any
more and Marisol and it goes wait this
is from at Marisol Nichols Skeet Ulrich
can run me over and I get died happy I'm
loving daddy's because of Riverdale damn
Hyrum lodges another daddy and I just
want to lick him like scream days yes
love it but like Skeets as FP Jones me
up I'm not sure what to do with I wish
it were 1984 because I'd make Molly
Ringwald fall in love with me is such a
dope I could barely focus on what's
actually happening in the show oh my god
I would lick tequila out of F P Jones's
bellybutton well I just hi hello I'd
call both Mark Consuelos
and the Huayra Lodge daddy this is where
I get to repeat the Nadia's Roberto joke
I ever made the initials for ski bulges
at his F
Jones dance for affable parent anyway
Hermione Lodge out here looking fine as
wine goodbye
boom everyone is like OMG at Cole
Sprouse is so hot and I'm like OMG Skeet
Ulrich is it daddy
[Music]
[Laughter]
I am quote why is Hiram Lodge such a
toxic boy dil who could call me and get
it years old and what what it's actually
verified get it years old it didn't make
any more no no we need a Millennials
does anybody know what that means it
means you're hot nobody can touch me
unless you are Marisol Nichols I think
I'll always have a crush
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay Molly ring this actually evens it
out so cute in friends for watching
please make sure you watch video on the
CW thank you
[Music]